how hard was it to persuade you to come
back for this film well I thought if
they do more movies they're not going to
ask us back we had a beginning a middle
and an end and George told us that if
you didn't want to come back we wouldn't
recast your part we'd write you out and
I as I left that meeting and I said to
my wife it's like we were drafted I mean
how am I supposed to say no I'd be the
most hated man on the planet I mean
there would be fans outside my house
like the angry villagers in a
Frankenstein picture with lightsabers
instead of torches so I mean there was
no I mean there's no wiggle room I
thought well you got to do it but that's
what we do that's what I'm in this
business I only want to make people
happy
and these people films make people very
happy we're not gonna give anything away
no spoilers but you have definitely got
the best role in this film you tap that
entrance it's not fun
and I tell fans they get very cross with
us and I say we're not teasing you we're
not trying to play mind games with you
it's basically trying to keep what I got
you for Christmas is surprise you don't
want to be save it for the movies don't
let it be ruined on the Internet it's
been like the second time around have
you appreciated it more is it be more
fun
absolutely you really that's a great
question because you're able to
appreciate it in a way you never were in
your 20s where you know that was my
first film what did I know that oh
they're all gonna be like this and you
know now I have a little perspective and
I'm I'm really enjoying in a way I did
before loving every moment other